january will open with a ceremony in
honor of parliament president david
sasoli who passed away on january the
11th
a member of the european parliament
since 2009 he was elected as president
in july 2019
parliament's due to elect his next
president in a scheduled vote
france holds the eu's rotating
presidency for the next six months
emmanuel macron is set to address
who will discuss france's agenda of
recovery strength and a sense of
belonging
parliament is set to vote on proposals
to better protect users of online
services like social media and
marketplaces
meps want new rules to counter illegal
content and products
and hold platforms accountable for their
algorithms
parliament's expected to back plans to
better equip europe for future health
crises
the proposed deal would give more power
to the european medicines agency to
tackle shortages of supplies and
equipment
meps will vote on ways of improving the
welfare of animals during transport
they want a more ethical and efficient
system which better takes into account
animals needs and limits journey times
for live exports
[Music]